breakthrough isn't much different from
watchdogs non DLC convoy missions it's
just a bit on the harder side since
you're in a densely populated part of
the loop and you have to take out your
two targets non-lethally if you drive
down the convoy path to meet your prey
half way you can get the advantage by
setting up in and around a train
platform especially if you love sniping
note that we're sporting the dead sec
outfit in these videos as it's one of
several new ensembles we're also showing
off the m1 SMG one of the two weapons
you unlock with this first wave of
season pass dlc
a nasty hanji between corporate Chicago
and mighty Quinn's cloths about to go
down and we want to know who shows up
unfortunately for us they've got too
well protected vehicles in the vicinity
armor scrambler so you find ourselves
death however we are not mute you will
be our voice I don't speak for dead site
but I'm in it means giving the club a
headache
out huh
Oh No oh crap
[ __ ]
out of the song
small ray ray
southbound train arriving shortly
whoa whoa
hello hello you're in over your head
hey
long people northbound train allowing
shortly
I'm taking you down [ __ ]
you don't have a [ __ ] chairs
he's gonna take a walk southbound train
arriving shortly best your special brand
chaos we now have invitations to the
party no doubt we will call way with
plenty of gossip here's a little
something to show our face make sure you
put that gossip to good use